c'est me palatine ce qu une petite ville
du kazakhstan ancienne république
soviétique du bout du monde
berik à 31 ans c'est le malade le plus
connu de son pays
nous l'avons filmé dans la pénombre de
multiples excroissance déforment son
visage et le font souffrir
aveugle de naissance il parle avec
difficulté
sauf
ça
[Musique]
un brick est une victime de la
radioactivité pendant des années
sa mère est née le cam a travaillé dans
une ferme à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres du champ de terreau atomique
au moment des essais nucléaires
[Musique]
bel 20 heures quand j'étais enceinte de
six mois de berric j'ai vu quelque chose
dans le ciel j'ai regardé il y avait une
lumière jamais je n'aurais pensé que mon
enfant serait malade à cause de ça mais
c'est ce que disent les médecins
j'aimerais au moins avoir un oeil pour
voir le visage de ma mère je ne n'ai
jamais vu ni ceux de mes proches je me
promène dans le jardin je ramasse du
bois qu'est-ce que je peux faire de ma
faim
berik sont rarement il a peur du bruit
de la foule aujourd'hui c'est différent
berry qui est heureux il vient
d'apprendre qu'un médecin allemand
accepte de l'opérer gratuitement pour le
soulager
il va fêter cette bonne nouvelle c'est
la première fois que berrick va au
restaurant son frère mes dettes toujours
avec lui le guide
les regards se détournent de belgique
medhat et bellick termineront la journée
au mémorial des victimes de l'attentât
qui reste bizarrement le passage obligé
de tous les jeunes mariés de la région
de 1949 à 1989 1 million 600 mille
personnes ont été irradiés par les
essais nucléaires de l'armée rouge 10%
de la population une population de plus
en plus malade le village de dordogne
est à 60 km de l'épicentre des
explosions avec le village de berric
c'est l'une des communes les plus
touchées par les radiations
laissé à l'abandon depuis l'effondrement
du régime soviétique de lognes autrefois
était l'un des villages les plus
importants de la région avec son hôpital
sa maison de la culture
une école et un lycée aujourd'hui seuls
ceux qui ne peuvent plus partir sont
encore là tous malades touchés par la
radiation comme l'aude milhas et ses
fils
c'est bon je vais leur donner leur thé
ça va les calmer
[Musique]
ce que nous entendons peut sembler un
gémissement en fait c'est un chant
taulier sacha chante tout le temps du
matin au soir
[Musique]
pourquoi tu te déshabiller ravi toi vite
il faut encore leur cirque
[Musique]
les deux frères sont nés en 1956 et 1958
mais il souffre de la même maladie loli
goffri ni un mal très répandue dans la
région
ils sont mentalement arriérés depuis
l'âge de 3 ans ils ont arrêté de parler
ils ne font que chantait il ne contrôle
pas toutes les fonctions de leur corps
et dépendent totalement de leur mère
personne à l'époque n'avait dit alou 2
milliards qu'il fallait se protéger des
radiations
en fait on a juste entendu un message à
la radio qui a ordonné des teintes
toutes les lumières à 18h et de fermer
les portes et toutes les fenêtres
s'évader on devait faire une provision
d'eau et utiliser les matelas et les
quads pour nous protéger et pour
protéger les portes et les fenêtres
surtout ils nous ont dit de rester à
l'extérieur
op à au moins 50 mètres de distance de
la maison nous pouvions rentrée qu'après
l'explosion
pour les villageois les explosions
nucléaires à ciel ouvert et est une
attraction
c'était comme ça comme un champignon un
grand champignon blonde puis il a changé
de couleur comme un soleil il y avait
des lignes dans le ciel le bruit a duré
sept minutes ça c'était terrifiant les
arbres ont tremblé faut mais les chiens
se sont cachés et les gens sont tombés
par terre du pot pas d'aller moi j'avais
les oreilles bouchées et j'ai été
projeté contre les grilles de ma maison
après quand ça a été fini on a été
autorisé à rentrer dans la maison on
pouvait enfin rouvrir les fenêtres mais
à l'intérieur tout était noir de
poussière sacha l'odm il ya et olia sont
des victimes du nucléaire comme tous
ceux qui habitaient cette région au
moment des explosions
les possèdent des passeports d'irradier
qui leur assure une petite pension et
des soins gratuits en ville
[Musique]
ce champ de tir se trouve à 60 km du
village de dordogne
nous nous y rendons en compagnie de
responsables kazakh dans une
fourgonnette militaire le périmètre de
la zone d'essai nucléaire qu'on appelle
ici le polygone est un territoire
immense grands comme l'île de france
nous n'en avons vu qu'une petite partie
voici les images d'époque les images de
propagande pendant 40 ans l'union
soviétique a fait exploser ici 456 bombe
atomique dont 116 à l'air libre
c'est une bombe de l'intensité des
roches ima pratiquement tous les mois
c'est la guerre froide staline dirige
d'une main de fer l'empiré soviétique
il veut tester sa capacité atomique et
prouver au monde entier que l'armée
rouge à une bombe capable de répondre à
celle des américains
aujourd'hui ce territoire est désert
mais les traces des expériences
atomiques sont toujours là en bout la
dyle manoff numéro 4 du ministère kazakh
de l'énergie nous fait la visite on se
trouve sur la zone des essais nucléaires
souterrains et aériens nazis derrière
moi c'est les restes des bâtiments en
fer et béton il y avait des chars des
avions des ponts des immeubles tous
construits avec des matériaux différents
placé à différentes distances de
l'épicentre on voulait tester leur
résistance et savoir jusqu'où pouvait
aller la vague destructrice de
l'explosion pour entrer dans la zone de
tir il nous a fallu une autorisation
spéciale
mais une fois sur place nous constatons
que ce territoire est pratiquement libre
d'accès
il est pourtant toujours dangereuse
notre compteur geiger indique une
radioactivité vent soit supérieur à la
norme autorisée
non il n'ya pas de patrouilles de
surveillance mais nous avons mis des
panneaux pour indiquer les 5% des
territoires les plus dangereux
l'une des zones les plus irradiés la
voici cela qu aucun panneau ne le
signale dans la région il est appelé le
lac atomique
nous ne pouvons y rester plus de 30
minutes sous peine d'être irradiés il a
été créé artificiellement par une
explosion nucléaire au croisement de
deux fleuves une première à l'époque la
propagande soviétique parler d'explosion
atomique au service de la paix
lors de la première explosion nucléaire
s'approche son objectif et nous apporter
la paix fletcher l'appareil
automatiquement programmer est en marche
et un peu commencé le décompte 2 0
[Musique]
g l'explosion vient de faire jaillir des
couches profondes au sol plus de 10
millions de mètres cubes de terre lors
de sa création pas un mot sur les
dangers de ce lac la propagande battait
son plein et encourager même les gens à
utiliser cette eau
[Musique]
des échantillons d'eau ont été prélevés
à divers endroits et à des moments
différents
les recherches ont montré que l'eau des
réservoirs artificiels formé par les
explosions nucléaires n'est pas
dangereuse pour l'homme
oh
elle est tout à fait potables et on peut
l'utiliser pour irriguer des changes
d'après et pour les animaux
à l'époque mais il a 12 ans baïev était
un enfant et comme tous les enfants de
son âge il se baigner dans les eaux qui
venait de sollac pas loin de là il y à
une vallée il y avait des écoles des
camps de jeunes pionniers
quand j'étais enfant on nous emmenait
fauché le foin on allait se baigner
j'ai péché aujourd'hui vingt ans trente
ans après je peux vous dire que la
moitié de mes camarades sont morts ils
ont tous eu un cancer
aujourd'hui encore les autorités
kazakhes ne savent pas quoi faire de ce
lac atomique qui restent libres d'accès
à 80 km du polygone le village de canard
deux mille habitants du temps des essais
atomiques
il était systématiquement couverts par
le nuage de l'explosion nucléaire
le docteur hakim bettiche kataïev
médecin chef de l'hôpital de kahina s'en
souvient très bien vue voilée donné
quand le vent souffle et vers les camps
militaires il n'y avait pas d'explosion
les militaires maîtriser la technique
il voulait vivre l'état pur comme si
nous ne voulions pas vivre il étudiait
la météo est au bout d'un moment quand
le vent souffler vers les villages les
gens commençaient à dire vital si le
vent souffle vers nous c'est qu'on va
avoir une explosion bientôt foule après
les explosions il y avait les plus
chaudes radioactives le but dans mon
enfance on aimait courir sous ces pluies
c'était notre passe-temps quatre buts
notre jeu cros tous les enfants le
faisait outre la proximité avec le
polygone de tir
l'intérêt de kayes marque pour les
militaires semblaient être ces montagnes
le polygone et là bas en viron 80 km
quand il y avait des explosions le vent
souffle et de là bas re stop et nous on
recevait des nuages radioactifs robots k
o
il restait là si les boîtes de gouin
c'est sur ces montagnes comme un chapeau
pendant plusieurs jours et après il y
avait les pluies show dont les pluies
radioactives foutu à coudes et tout ça
ça venait du polygone
le docteur hakim bey y jouer comme les
autres sous les pluies chaude
il se sait condamné mais il continue son
travail au village nuages atomiques plus
radioactives dès la fin des années 50
des maladies inconnues jusque là ont
fait leur apparition un canard et les
scientifiques ont commencé à parler d'un
syndrome de cannes a parfois du jour au
lendemain plus rien ne marche dans le
corps il s'affaiblit les maladies se
multiplient et la mort survient
rapidement alors que nous accompagnons
le docteur dans sa tournée à l'hôpital
on vient lui annoncer que son infirmière
a déclaré le syndrome de canard elle a
les yeux dilatées est ce que je dois
venir faire un diagnostic
elle n'a plus besoin de diagnostic c'est
trop tard elle est en train de mourir et
on lui avait donné tous les médicaments
la mère de l'infirmière et effondré le
docteur hakim bay se rend au chevet de
la jeune femme mais elle décédera un peu
plus tard dans l'après midi
le docteur hakim bey y commence sa
tournée à domicile
nous l'accompagnons chez bach ou de
goranova maire de trets enfants cinq
sont morts bébé les huit autres sont
handicapés mentaux tous possèdent des
passeports d'irradier barque où tu étais
bergère et durant les explosions
nucléaires à ciel ouvert comme tout le
monde elle regardait le champignon
atomique
son fils hayes essaye de nous parler au
jeu je ne sais pas pourquoi je suis
comme ça pas comme les autres je marche
comme tout le monde mais je n'arrive pas
à le faire normalement je travaille tout
nickel je garde les moutons mais j'ai
mal j'ai mal dans mon corps même si je
mange quelque chose j'ai mal je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
baroud subvient seul aux besoins de sa
famille sa fille candle 26 ans a été
envoyé dans une institution spécialisée
mais à cause de son extrême faiblesse
physique et mentale elle a été renvoyée
chez elle
aujourd'hui elle vit dans la terreur
d'avoir à nouveau acquitté sa mère je ne
souhaite que deux choses dans la vie
rester à la maison et que maman soit
toujours en bonne santé
[Musique]
dans le polygone il y a aussi une ville
qui pendant longtemps à figurer sur
aucune carte kurchatov du nom du père de
l'atome elle est située à 45 kilomètres
du champ tir dès la fin des années 40
jusqu'à la fermeture du site nucléaire
en 89 30 mille scientifiques et
militaires soviétiques et ont vécu en
autarcie dans le plus grand des secrets
coupé du monde par deux rangées de
barbelés le kgb la police secrète de
moscou y régner en maître aujourd'hui
les bureaux du kgb son désert mais huit
mille personnes vivent encore dans cette
ville
tous
voici le musée de l'atome tout ce qui a
fait la puissance de cette ville est
réuni dans cette pièce machines affiche
de propagande maquette du polygone avec
les petits avions et les animaux cobayes
et même la salle de contrôle avec le
bouton de mise à feu
nous y retrouvons en boule à dilma nov
cet homme a travaillé dix ans dans le
secret à moscou puis 20 ans ministère de
l'énergie kazakh
il sait que les habitants des villages
des alentours sont tous malades
mais il justifie quand même les essais
nucléaires mais je sors oui bien sûr ses
essais atomiques ont permis de grandes
avancées dans les domaines de la
physique nucléaire physique et de la
chimie et dans d'autres domaines de la
science mais on ne pouvait pas imaginer
les conséquences néfastes sur la
population ni tout noir laisse un
minimum pourtant les militaires et les
scientifiques devaient bien s'en douter
pendant 40 ans les explosions ont été
programmés uniquement lorsque les vents
poussaient les nuages radioactifs dans
la direction des villages et jamais
quand il soufflé vers la ville des
scientifiques qui se teignent anastacio
tête un hasard ce n'était pas commander
car cela dépend des uniquement du temps
seuls les conditions métérologiques
déterminée elle est une pure coïncidence
si le nuage atomique se dirigeait
toujours vers la région d'al taille et
de semipalatinsk
pour le ministère de l'énergie
la contamination des villages autour du
champ de tir est donc le fruit du hasard
les passeports d'irradier délivré par
les autorités kazakhes n'aurait qu'une
valeur médicale
sergei loukachenko directeur de
l'institut des radiations et de la
sécurité nucléaire va même encore plus
loin
c'est quelqu'un de berric est une preuve
des conséquences des essais atomiques
ma réponse est non et non ça n'est pas
une preuve quand vous parlez du syndrome
de canard et de quelques autres cas ce
ne sont que des cas isolés
il y en a un deux trois quatre cinq
peut-être tout le monde connaissait cas
mais la seule preuve serait des
statistiques médicales statistiques
or il n'y a aucune preuve de vie entre
la santé de la population et atomic gens
si il n'y a aucune preuve belgique n'est
pas une preuve un nom bay berrigan n'est
pas une preuve ses frères de dolo dit
non non non non les monstruosités ne
sont pas des preuves non non non non non
non je ne sont pas les preuves
si vous êtes sérieux comme commercial
absolument show elle
des preuves pourtant nous allons en
trouver l'institut médical des
radiations à s'aimer palatine ce qu
était du temps des soviétiques
un laboratoire classés top secret il
dépend des uniquement du kgb
c'était le fameux bloc numéro 4 où l'on
étudié les villageois contaminé
bollywood chef était un jeune médecin au
moment des tests atomiques
aujourd'hui il part à la retraite il
accepte pour la première fois de se
confier à une télévision occidentales
ces révélations ne laisse aucun doute
nous étions une unité de scientifiques
triés sur le volet l'unité comptait 142
personnes dont 42 médecin pour l'époque
en 1962 c'était assez important il nous
avons pu organiser des missions dans
différentes régions avec des équipes de
6 8 personnes et des infirmières aussi
des données cd du mois de mai jusqu'à la
fin novembre
nous prélevons des échantillons de sang
et d'uriné
je t'aurais terre et nous restions dans
ce village nous observer la population
après vers la fin de l'année
17e nous devions rendre nos rapports le
louisiana state a dit nadine le
gouvernement voulait voir ce qui pouvait
se passer si la population restait seul
face à la bombe atomique
en cas de guerre avec les états unis a
nié tôt j'ai pris ce qu'a dit les états
unis le polygone et est le révélateur
des conséquences des explosions
atomiques
car ici on utilisait des bombes très
puissantes sur une population livrée à
elle-même mini clip on voyait que les
gens ne mourrai pas par milliers mais
qu'il développait des cancers et des
maladies liées à la circulation du sang
voyait côté médias à l'époque on
appelait ça les pertes médical que
latéral et eldad
bélie sacha theolia l'odm il ya les
dizaines de milliers de villageois
irradié n'aurait donc été rien d'autre
que des cobayes pour les dirigeants de
l'époque
c'est en tout cas ce que prouvent ses
cartes secrètes du kgb qui montre
l'évolution des nuages radioactifs
au-dessus des villages des villages qui
n'était ni prévenu ni évacués chaque
couleur correspond à une nouvelle
explosion
tout était planifié prémédité le premier
bébé monstrueux nous l'avons eue à canal
ici c'était le village le plus proche du
polygone à 80 kilomètres et les doses de
radiation là bas étaient très forts
rigole quand les soviétiques quittant 89
le kazakhstan bollywood chef devient le
premier directeur de l'institut de
radiologie médicale
et pour cause c'est lui qui sauve en
cachette
80% des archives de l'époque et les
cartes secrètes du kgb mais était ce
style est censé documents tous nos
travaux par total au à 100 pas cela et
puis ensuite on s'est dit que cela
pouvait aussi aider la population aux
malades qui étaient tous les cours
[Musique]
grâce à ces archives des enfants comme
ça ils n'eurent né trois ans après la
fermeture du polygone sont reconnus
comme des victimes des essais atomiques
ils ont eu aussi des passeports
d'irradier mais pour my radio mcd elena
maman de zain sûrs cela ne suffit pas
[Musique]
on a fêté la fermeture du polygone le
président nazarbaïev est même venu et
alors pourquoi on ne nous donne pas
d'appartement oui on a aucune aide
sauf les 145 euros de pension qu'on nous
verse tous les mois aux designers à 17
ans mais ce n'est que l'année dernière
qu'elle a obtenu un fauteuil roulant
avant c'était sa mère qu'il apportait
tout le temps à bout de bras pas d'eau
courante pas de sanitaires pas de
travail peu de revenus mayra est l'une
des rares qui refusent de se résigner
[Musique]
tous ces papiers c'est pour obtenir des
couches-culottes gratuite
il me demande tellement de certificats
pour obtenir ces couches que je vais
devenir folle c'est moi qui bientôt ira
à l'hôpital
on attend d'être tour pour un
appartement
j'ai même écrit une lettre au président
en 2008 et j'ai la preuve
vingt ans après l'arrêt des essais
atomiques
les naissances d'enfants malades
difformes ou handicapées sont toujours
trois fois plus élevé ici que dans le
reste du monde
à la maternité de semih palatine ce qu'à
150 kilomètres du champ de tir
les naissances prématurées sont elles
deux fois plus fréquentes
[Musique]
le professeur te le cal norman golb
étoffe directeur de la maternité et
spécialiste de la génétique s'en est
fait une raison
dans la région 'l'indice de santé des
femmes en âge de procréer et de 10%
cela veut dire que neuf femmes sur dix
sont malades
or il ya une règle d'or une femme malade
donne naissance à des enfants malades
c'est une donnée générale il n'ya plus
d'explosions on est donc censé être en
bonne santé mais n'ont pas du tout cas
les effets de la radiation sont toujours
là on se les transmet de génération en
génération
pendant ce temps le gène affectés ne
disparaît pas ici vous savez le futur ce
n'est plus les monstres non pas du tout
notre avenir c'est les mutants montant à
l'académie de médecine de la ville on a
justement conservés dans des bocaux des
bébés difformes menées au sein de la
population est radié et ce jusque dans
les années 85
ces naissances sont de moins en moins
fréquentes mais elles n'ont pas pour
autant disparu
à l'orphelinat de la ville les nouveaux
nés abandonnés à cause de leur handicap
mental ou moteurs sont toujours aussi
nombreux
adil à trois ans c'est un enfant
hydrocéphale et il n'a pas de cerveau il
ne peut ni marcher ni parler il est
aveugle mais il reconnaît les voies et
plus particulièrement celle de la
docteure simbad celles d'asie evenat qui
s'occupe de lui ou montgeron taggia
d'état on ne peut pas le tenir ni le
porter car sa tête est immense 66 cm au
lieu des 40 comme c'est la norme et sa
tête ne cessent de grandir et à mayotte
nous travaillons ici et nous avons eu
cinq enfants hydrocéphales pensent tout
bas
mais c'est dur même pour nous qui
travaillons ici voire cinq enfants
hydrocéphales avec des têtes comme ça
c'est trop à mon avis il ya un rapport
avec le polygone c'est certain les gens
s'habituent à la naissance d'enfants
handicapés de génération en génération
vous pouvez cependant la désintégration
de la radioactivité
entre 100 et 1000 ans est prête à man et
nous avons une accumulation de
radiations d'une génération sur l'autre
dieu comme il ya cet avorton des régates
et j'ai peur que les cinquième et
sixième génération soit bien pire
iata joyeuse à vrai dire j'ai peur de
faire des pronostics
le gouvernement kazakh ne semble pas
vouloir aider davantage ses victimes de
la radiation
en revanche il se dit prêt à rendre
prochainement les terres du polygone à
l'exploitation civile et même à
l'agriculture c'est l'une des priorités
et des relais bâti bercoff numéro deux
du ministère de l'énergie et des
ressources minérales du pays
nasa d'atg aujourd'hui notre but
primordial c'est de rendre utilisables
95% de la terre du polygone la rendre
scène pour toute utilisation y compris
l'agriculture n'y a pas de rayons ne
peut pas considérer tout le territoire
du polygone
de la même manière ou cage d'avoir
routière ce casque est tout cas chaque
zone à sa propre réglementation pour sa
réhabilitation et sa future exploitation
tôt
l'une des techniques envisagées pour
nettoyer le polygone c'est d'enlever 10
cm de terre la surface du sol mais cela
soulève d'importantes polémiques
pour michael palin à la tête du
département écologique de série palatine
c'que c'est même à mon sens si on enlève
ses terres des zones fortement
contaminée cela pose le problème de la
manutention de cette terre et de son
stockage combat est à moi c'est le même
problème que les déchets nucléaires
où allons-nous les m c'est une grande
perte de temps et d'argent
c'est vraiment un grand problème selon
michael pagny c'est en réalité le
sous-sol du polygone que les autorités
du kazakhstan veulent récupérer un sous
sol qui regorgerait d'or d'argent et de
charbon
d'où les efforts intenses pour sa
réhabilitation alors même que la
radioactivité continue de faire des
ravages
le sol l'eau la chaîne alimentaire de la
région qui dépasse les frontières du
polygone sont contaminés plus grave
encore le patrimoine génétique humain a
été irrémédiablement modifié au
kazakhstan et personne ne peut prédire
les conséquences de la radiation dans
les années à venir
[Musique]